when you ask anyone in society hey man  how are you doing most people will give  you the answer fine good okay all of  which aren't emotions I mean you could  have the worst thing happening in your  life today and be like I'm fine I'm okay  it's okay you're not okay  um and that doesn't mean like you're not  going to be okay forever you just ask  for help there's support you know my  life today I can't get through it  without this you know I have I'm part of  a men's group I I go to 12-step meetings  regularly on Zoom there is help out  there it's not hopeless and we need it  we're not equipped to deal with what's  happening in the world so the way we get  through it is through connection